luis patino that gets it started and his
limited work he has been very impressive
here's aaron judge
and that one is wrapped into center
field and deep going back is phillips
turning looking sia that was out in an
eye blink and the yankees lead one
nothing no time for you to say see it
that was an absolute missile just a line
drive dead center field and now there's
a man aboard with one in and luke voigt
is going to make his
2021 debut
swinging and amazing strikes him out and
boyd is out on strikes and that'll do it
for the yankees here in the first jordan
montgomery this will be a seven start
and here's austin meadows
strike three
down goes meadows and a one two three
inning
sanchez here with one out nobody aboard
and a wave and a miss and sanchez
missed the slider
strikeout number two for pitino well we
know that sanchez will
expand the zone tino does a great job of
exploiting that weakness and picking up
a punch-out
so now clint frazier
was lifted back at third foul padlow
gets out there from third base down to
the bullpen and makes a nice little
catch right there
so it's three up and three down there'll
be a one-two from monty to
brussels
and the pitch is cut out and missed
beautiful change by montgomery
and they're a two-way second strikeout
you see the circle change up turns it
over way out in front just enough
movement great pitch so here's kevin
padlow
swing and a miss montgomery looks sharp
montgomery has another one two three
and we have played two tonight down in
tampa for the eggs of second and third
and one out
and that one gets passino
so scoring is lemayou stanton will move
to third the yankees lead two nothing
this ball just took off see almost just
like a cutter three
two liner into left that'll be caught by
a rose arena stanton's gonna hang on
at third base
two gone
and here's our shella
fly ball into right field margot is
there and boy the rays will take that go
to the third mike dimino starts it
against jordan montgomery
there's one high and deep in out of here
a blast by zanino
and the razor on the board
a 3-2 pitch and zenino
powers this one out to center field that
ball was an absolute rocket out of here
swing and a miss adamus down on strikes
oh here's brett phillips
swinging to miss phillips down on
strikes we're headed into the fourth
inning luke voight stepping in to lead
it off for new york
and now voight
hit by a pitch
first pitch
roy slowly makes his way up the first
base line
there's the fastball trying to go away
runs it up and in and gets voight right
on
the inside of that right hand wrist area
you could see the look on his face too
like really i just got off the il i just
got hit in the hand and here we go again
with these two teams
the runner at first voight with one out
two to one new york and now gary sanchez
ground ball third
padlo brasso one first base two they get
them both around the horn
the double play ball off the bat
of sanchez
and walmart go and a base headline
through the left side toward the corner
he'll turn first gonna dig for two and
he'll make it ahead of the throw in
standing with a double
first and second one man out
montgomery with seven strikeouts
57 pitches for the left-hander
and a miss strikeout number eight for
montgomery he has really overworked his
change up tonight and another good one
who comes over he's trailing by run two
to one he'll be facing frazier gardner
and le mayhew and well kind of a cat
mouse situation with fleming and lemay
here i thought you were talking about
the music and i was surprised
swung out and this one is driven in the
air to right field but
playable from our go back if stefan will
make the catch in that will retire the
side they're going to need to hit at
least another home run
pistol zunino hit in the air to center
field gardner going back he makes a
catch and there's one away and that will
bring up willy adams
2-2
swing and a miss
he's now tied his career high that's his
ninth strikeout of the game
just off the il
his second plate appearance hit on the
hand by a pitch fly ball deep into right
all the way to the wall
and that ball is caught
had some carry on it margot stayed with
it and voight
is out number one in the seventh
there's gary sanchez
high fly ball right field deep again
going back more go track wall see ya
home run for sanchez and it's 3-1
yankees is that good enough match-up for
you there michael again gary sanchez
does not have to worry about catching up
to the fastball from fleming he can stay
in there go with it the other way
great piece of hitting after stepping
out and slowing him down
so one on and two out and that will
bring up gardner setting up inside
that's where the pitch is and it hits
gardner
[Applause]
and he will take first
second yankee hitter
hit by a pitch
voigt in the fourth now gardner here in
the seventh
right on the underneath part of the hand
not a good spot
for brett gardner
no here is zunino with two outs and a
runner on the 2-2
swing and a miss he got him
as tampa has now struck out 10 times
first strikeout by lewis again the
infield's coming in with stanton at
third and judge at first or shallow the
hitter and it's already 3-1 new york one
for three on the evening ground ball to
second
and they throw to the plate they're
going to get the out there
so stanton
sliding his way toward the plate
is out number one the ground ball right
at lao
okay got plenty of time
i'll tell you what though cenino had to
kind of help him out there with that
little scoop on the low throw and then
the tag
two on one out now it's luke voight
ground ball
short stop
second base one first base two
adamos wow to diaz
you know here is margot with two outs
theo on
grounded to third urshella across the
diamond
and mouse ago with two shutout innings
here is chapman not only is chapman
seven for seven and save opportunities
his era is 0.00
so the rays get a base runner on the
error and again they will get the
potential tying run to the plate here's
yandy diaz
and that one way past sanchez he fires
the second
and they got him oh oh what a
perfect hop back to sanchez carried off
the
rotating sign and he gets meadows
well this is a home
home ballpark i mean as a player you
have to know what happens at the
backstop but gary sanchez alert
gets this ball and just guns out meadows
so there are two way and that will be uh
brandon lau
and he is the tying run
one two
swung running misty got him the stare to
save the win for the yankees three to
one 100 miles an hour laos swings
through it and the yankees get the first
game of this three-game set